The aging process is
plastic, it's malleable.
It's not fixed and
it is not something
that must occur invariably
in the same sequence
and with the same level of
disability going forward.
We can impact it a lot.
And so this is one
part of where we're
trying to contribute from
the side of the immune system
to this extension of
what we call health span.
Which is good health
in which you're
going to spend as many years
as possible in your life.
You think about people who
have lived into their 70s,
into their 80s, into their 90s.
And thinking about what they
can return to the society
is really remarkable.
I mean, they are some of the
wisest people that you have.
We, on the other
hand, figure out OK,
well if you have retired or
even if you haven't retired,
you know, whatever.
It's like you know, you're like
on the margin of the society.
And that's really wrong.
Human potential is really not
determined by those years.
You know, we don't really
have an expiration date
until which we're
useful to the society.
So that is the
other part that has
crystallized for me
as an important issue
and an important goal.